[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم وكل عام وانتم بخير نحن
اليوم حديثنا في برنامج الندوى عن يوم
التاسيس وهو اليوم الذي تم اعتماده
وتم الاحتفال به المره الاولى نحن بصدد
الاحتفال به للمره الثانيه من شهر فبراير
وهو بمناسبه تاسيس او تولي الامير محمد بن
سعود جده الاسره السعوديه زمام الامور في
الدرعيه عام 1727 هذا التاريخ يعتبر نقله
نوعيه في الوعي التاريخي السعودي والعربي
ايضا اذ انه جعل لحظه الانطلاق الحقيقيه
هي اللحظه التي تولى فيها محمد بن سعود
الحكم في الدرعيه وليست لحظه لقاء الامام
او الامير محمد بن سعود بالشيخ محمد بن
عبد الوهاب وان كانت هذه اللحظه مهمه
لكنها تاتي لحظه
تابعه للحظه الاولى ولحظه انطلاق الشراره
الاولى حين
اشرقت الدنيا
واشرق اقليم العارضي بتولي الامير محمد بن
سعود للحكم اذا موضوعنا هو عن يوم التاسيس
نحاول ان نتفرس اكثر في ملامح هذا اليوم
دلالاته خلفياته مالاته ولماذا هو يوم مهم
شريكنا في الندوه اليوم هو الدكتور
والباحث السعودي راشد بن عساكر مرحبا بك
يا دكتور راشد الدكتور راشد بالمناسبه
يعتبر من خيره المتخصصين في تاريخ الدوله
السعوديه
بكل اطوارها ورسالته للدكتوراه اصلا هي عن
الدوله السعوديه الثانيه ويملك كم
مميز من الوثائق التي تختص بهذا التاريخ
اذن
[موسيقى]
حينما نقول ال سعود والاسره السعوديه
ربما البعض لا يدري عن الجذور التاريخيه
لهذه الاسره فهلا
وضعتنا في لمحه تاريخيه تعطينا خلفيه عن
هذه الاسره طبعا الاسره من الاسرات ايضا
كانت القديمه موجوده في منطقه العارضه
اللي هي الاسره المالكه في جدهم الاعلى
مانع المريدي وهذه الاسره قديما كانت هنا
في حجر اليمامه في الرياض
في الرياض في في تقريبا قبل القرن ايضا
التاسع الهجري بعد تقريبا سنه 850
انتقلت هذه الاسره الى شرق الجزيره
العربيه لما ايضا الصيدلات الموجوده بين
ايضا هذه المنطقه وايضا بمنطقه الاحساء
وكما نعلم ايضا ابن مقرب العيوني الشاعر
الدولي العيونيه في الاحساء كان هنا ايضا
في الرياض في حجر اليمامه ولهذا كانت له
قصائد ايضا التبادل التجاري وايضا التبادل
الحضاري فيما بين هذه المنطقه العارضه
ايضا الاحساء الاتصال وادوات التواصل
قريبه اما سياسيا وايضا دينيا واجتماعيا
وثقافيا وغير اقتصاديا ولهذا انتقل افراد
من هذه الاسره المالكه عندما كانوا هنا في
حجر اليمامه انتقلوا الى الاحساء واستمر
الى ابناء عمومتهم لان هذه الاسره تنتسب
الى قبيله بني حنيفه وهذه القبيله هي
المسيطره على هذه المنطقه منذ الجاهليه
وايضا الاسلام وحتى الفترات القريبه الى
يومنا الحاضر لان هذه الاسره هذه مواطنهم
القديمه
كونها قبيله حضريه حاولت ايضا الانتشار في
هذا الوادي منذ قبل الاسلام الى الفترات
الحاليه فالشاهد هنا انتقال هذه الاسره
السعوديه الى الاحساء ثم
بداتهم الاعلى مانع المريدي جدهم الاعلى
فصار هناك تواصل بين هذا الجد الاعلى
للاسره السعوديه مانع المريدي وبين ايضا
امير الرياض ابن عمهم عبد المحسن بن سعيد
الدرعي الحنفي فكان هذا التواصل والاتصال
فيما بينهم ثم اقترح ايضا في هذا التواصل
كما يقول المؤرخون لما بين الاثنين من
المواصله والمراحمه وكونهم ايضا من هذه
القبيله فانتقل بالتالي جد الاسره المالكه
مانع المريدي الى بعد ما طلبه ابن عمه ان
يقطعه ارضا فاقطعه ارض شمال حجر اليمامه
وشمال الرياض التي هي تقريبا الان الدرعيه
التي قامت على موضعا قديم يسمى موضع الضيق
وغبيره كان هذا اسم الجاهليه وايضا واول
الاسلام ثم تحول الى المليبيد وغصيبه
الان في الدرعيه تقع في الجهه الجنوبيه
منها في موضع يقال له العلاقيه واما غصيبه
فايضا في موقع الطريف من ناحيه الشماليه
في يقال له
يعني الموضع الشاهد هناك غصيبه فالدرعيه
يتكونت من عده احياء كان اسمها قديم كما
ذكرت الضيق وغبيره ثم اصبح المليبيد
وغصيبه وبعض الاحيان يطلق على المليبيت
الملابيت بصفه الجمع او المليبد بصفه ايضا
المفرد ثم في هذه الفتره التاريخيه انتقل
ايضا جد الاسره السعوديه واستقر هناك مانع
بن ربيع مانع المريدي ابنه ربيعه انتقل
لسنه 800 تقريبا وخمسين من الهجره وبدا
ايضا هذا الاستيطان اعاده الاستيطان ايضا
لهذه المنطقه وبالتالي انتشر هذا الذريه
هذه الاسره اذا هذا الموضع من الاساس وهو
تسكنه اسر من بني حنيفه الذي صنعه مانع
المريدي هو انه اعاد احياء سنه موجوده
وقديمه وكان هذا الوادي ايضا نفوذه او
يفوز فيه لاسر بني حنيفه بدلاله تسميته
الميزه التي تقع على هذا الجانب بهذا
الوادي وايضا بما يحمله من الصفات ايضا
الاقتصادي والزراعيه وايضا الحضاريه هو
قديم العهد يعني ليس بجديدا ولهذا اغلب
المدن تقع على اطرافه في الجهه من الجهه
الغربيه او الشرقيه ولهذا تاتي اهميته
ايضا من ضمن هذه المنطقه
اثناء هطول الامطار وفي مصاعد للماء وفيها
مقومات حياه زراعيه ورعاويه وغير ذلك لو
تحدثنا عن محمد بن سعود الذي من اسمه نسبت
الاسره من اسم والدها بالحقيقه
كم بين محمد بن سعود وجده الاعلى مانع
المريدي هو بين طبعا مانع المريدي عندما
بدا الحكم ايضا والانتقال لهذه الجهه هناك
انجب ابنه ربيعه ولهذا يخلط بعض المؤرخين
انهم يذكرون مانع بالربيع المريضى وهذا
ليس صحيحا بل المانع هو الجد الاعلى وله
ابن ربيع وربيعه ايضا تسلسل منه عدد من
الابناء الحقيقه بينهم تقريبا الفتره
الحكم يعني من سنه 850 الى في عام 1139
الى فتره الامام محمد بن سعود استمر على
اماره الدرعيه من هذالين الفرعين المقرن
والوطبان ايضا نتفرع منهم نعم وايضا الجد
الاعلى ابراهيم بن موسى بن ربيعه بن مانع
المريدي الذي كان يحمي ايضا المنطقه وجدت
له الوثائق ايضا في الدول الخارجيه سنه
981 عندما كان ايضا يحمي هذه المنطقه فمنذ
ذلك التاريخ هذه المرحله من سنه 850 الى
عام 1139 استمر ايضا هناك عدد من افراد
هذه الاسره الحاكمه تقريبا العشرين شخص 20
ومحمد بن سعود هو الرقم 21 من حكام الدوله
منذ حسب نظريه ابن خلدون في الاجيال
تعرفها لكل ثلاث اشخاص من الاباء يعني انت
وابي ووالدك وجدك تشكلوا 100 عام بالنسبه
تقريبيه تقريبا ولهذا بدات حكم الاسره
السعوديه يعني ليس حكما قريبا انظر الى
الفتره التاريخيه القديمه ربما من اكبر
يعني اطول الاسرات الحاكمه في العالم او
في واقعنا المحلي وايضا الاقليم ولهذا من
سنه 850 كما ذكرت الى عام 1239 21 حاكم
لهذه المنطقه الواحد والعشرين هو الامام
محمد بن سعود بن محمد طبعا ليس بالضروره
انكم كلهم
بس من ابناء عموم اجداده بان الجد الاعلى
الرابط والجد الاعلى الذي انتشر من هذه
الاسره في جدهم الاعلى ابراهيم وابراهيم
ايضا له السلطه وله القوه وله الوثيقه
ايضا كما ذكرنا الذي كان يحمي الحجاج
وتفرع منها اربع افرع رئيسيه
لماذا شخصيه محمد بن سعود مهمه قبل
ان يلتقي بمحمد بن عبد الوهاب هو لا شك
الفترات التاريخيه التي اتى محمد بن سعود
فيها الامير محمد بن سعود هناك ايضا
الحقيقه نجد
هناك مصادر يعني لم تصل لنا الحقيقه لكن
ربما بالتتبع التاريخي ندرك اهميه ايضا
هذا الرجل وهذا الرجل ايضا كانت هناك ايضا
بعض الاشياء الاشكاليات وايضا بعض الحروب
الدائره في هذه المنطقه ومحمد بن سعود هو
اللي كان البارز في بها وعندما توفي يعني
امير الدرعيه عندما انتقالهم ايضا الى
العيينه ومحاوله ايضا كانت التخلص من في
في العيينه لكن هو
قتل في تقريبا عام 1106 قبل الامام محمد
بن سعود ب 32 سنه ولهذا عندما تولد هام
الحكم في منفوحه وعند طرده من منفوحه
واتجاهه الى الرياض راى محمد بن سعود كتب
دهان بن دواسي الى محمد بن سعود ان اهل
الرياض قاموا ضدي فاريد ايضا هذه القوه
منك ان تقوم بايضا بدعم فتولى الحقيقه
محمد مسعود فارس جيش الى بقياده اخيه
مشاري فاحكم السيطره على الرياض وجعل دهان
ابن دواس اميرا على الرياض بسبب بسبب نصره
محمد بن سعود للدهان بن دواس تمكن من حكم
الرياض من حكم لان محمد بن سعود ادرك هناك
خلافا سياسيا قبله في حكام الرياض لان
الحكام الرضاعه اعتدوا ايضا على الدعيه
بالتالي ايضا في منفوعه فتمكن بالتابعه
ولها دلاله مهمه سنتوقف عند لماذا محمد بن
سعود كان لو كان امير محل اكتفى بشؤون
امارته المحليه يعني ماذا بمقاييس ذلك
الوقت يعتبر تدخل في شؤون اخرى يعني قد
يكون الامر له معنى سياسي عميق جدا لكن
استميحك عذرا بفاصل وجيز ثم نكمل هذا
الحديث عن اهميه شخصيه محمد بن سعود
المؤسس فلا تذهبوا بعيدا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد الحديث عن يوم التاسيس
الذي
سيظلنا قريبا
وهو مناسبه تاسيس الدوله السعوديه في
بذرتها الاولى عن طريق الامير او الامام
المؤسس محمد بن سعود حين تولى اماره
الدرعيه 1727 قبل لقائه الشهير الذي دائما
يرغب بعض الناس وما زالوا بجعل هذه اللحظه
هي لحظه البدايه لحظه اللقاء بالشيخ محمد
بن عبد الوهاب على اهميتها طبعا وموضوع
الحلف الديني السياسي
ضيفنا الدكتور راشد العساكر هو متخصص
الحقيقه في التاريخ السعودي وبشكل ادق في
تاريخ اقليم العارض والدوله السعوديه
باطوارها الثلاث خاصه الاولى والثانيه
توقف ضيفنا عند اهميه بعد استعراضه لتاريخ
الاسره القديم من 850 هجري عنده شخصيه
محمد بن سعود وانه كان لديه
محاولات او
تجليات سياسيه معينه قبل لحظه اللقاء
الشهير
اللقاء الديني كنت تحدثت عن ان امير
الدرعيه محمد بن سعود بعث بعثه عسكريه الى
امير الرياض الهام بن دواس لمساعدته
كيف تم هذا الامر وماذا تفهم منه هو
المساعده العسكريه طلبها دم بن دواس من
الامام محمد بن سعود فكان ايضا الامام
محمد بن سعود لديه تطلع ايضا في محاوله
لملمه ايضا هذه الظروف المحيطه ايضا
الجوانب الامنيه وايضا مد السيطره على هذه
المدينه الرياض وهذا التي تحقق الحقيقه
بالتالي عندما اوظن ولعل هذا يذكرنا ايضا
بفكره ايضا جد الاسره السعوديه ابراهيم بن
موسى بن ربيعه بن مانع عندما كان يتحاول
ان يمتد شمالا وايضا ان يقضي على ايضا
الخصوم في الجهات الشماليه في القرن
العاشر الهجري وتوسع ايضا في في في تلك
الناحيه فالمقصود انه قضيه ايضا محمد بن
سعود في جزء من هذه الامور انه يريد ايضا
ضبط وايضا علاقات تقويه ايضا علاقاته
الجانبيه ايضا في المدن القريبه وايضا
ايضا الامر او العامل الامني الذي يريد ان
ينظر له ايضا في
جزء اخر من الحديث اذا هذه ممكن نلخصها ما
تفضلت فيه
محاولات محمد بن سعود وجده الاعلى ابراهيم
ابن موسى ضمن ان اسميه الجينات السياسيه
يعني هذا الامر يدور في جيناتهم السياسيه
محاوله ايجاد نوع من انواع الوحده
والسيطره لكن الانفجار الكبير الانفجار
بالمعنى الايجابي هو نشات الدوله السعوديه
الاولى الحقيقيه لماذا نشات الدوله
السعوديه الاولى وما هو وما هي الاصوات
التي كانت تطلبها هو دائما عندما ينظر
الحقيقه المراه لواقع المنطقه منطقه
العارض يجد انه ربما بعض الخصائص المميزه
لهذه الجهه يعني نجدها الخصائص المميزه
ايضا من ناحيه الدينيه مثلا نجد العدد
الكبير ايضا من هؤلاء العلماء الذين مروا
على هذه المنطقه يعني اذا كان في فتره
الامام محمد بن سعود تقريبا حصرنا العلماء
من كتاب الشيخ عبد الله بن بسام الذين في
فتره الامام محمد بن سعود قرابه 94 الى
100 عالم فقط في فتره الامام محمد هناك
فترات ايضا سابقه قديمه ايضا لهؤلاء
العلماء وتواجدهم ايضا في هذه المنطقه لكن
كانت النظره الكبيره لدى المجتمع الحقيقه
تركز ايضا على هذا الجانب الذي نريد ان
نتطرق له وهو الجانب الامني الذي ارى الذي
استطع الامام تفعيل عند هذه النقطه الجانب
الامني يعني كان المجتمع ونخب تلك المجتمع
كانت في وقته اما علماء الدين او الامراء
او الشعراء وربما التجار هذول اللي يشكلون
النخبه والبقيه مجتمعات اميه تقريبا يعني
لفتني مقاله كتبها عالم الاجتماع السعودي
او عالم الانثروبولوجيا والمؤرخ
والعالم الكبير الدكتور سعد الصويان كتب
عام 2009 يحاول ان يقرا من خلال الشعر
النبطي كيف كان اهالي نجد بالدرجه الاولى
يتطلعون الى نشاه كيان سياسي يلم شتاتهم
هو استعرضها من خلال ثلاث نماذج شعراء
بعضهم لم يدرك الدوله السعوديه وبعضهم
ادرك بدايتها الذين لم يدركوا رميزان بن
غشام من منطقه سدير وجبر بن سيار من منطقه
القصب قريه او بلده القصد نقول مدينه
اليوم عشان ما يزعلوا كل مدينه القصب في
اقليم الوشم والثالث ايضا من نفس البلده
شاعر الشرير احمدان بص حمدان ادرك بدايه
الدوله الاولى
سعد استعرض اشعاره هؤلاء وهو تعرف ضليع في
تدوين الشعر الشعبي وقراءته ثم قال جمله
لفتتني في مقالتها التي نشرت عام جريده
الاقتصاديه يقول لو قرانا اشعار هؤلاء
الثلاثه بتمعن لخلصنا الى ان المنطقه كانت
قد سئمت حاله الشتات والتشرذم السياسي
وانعدام الامن والاستقرار ثم يقول الدكتور
سعد واصبح الناس يتطلعون الى قيام سلطه
تحقق العدل وتبسط الامن والنظام
والاستقرار لا اريد ان اطيل لانه توسع في
استعراض الشواهد الشعريه في هذا الامر هل
تتفق معه او اتفق معه
ويتمم هذا الحديث الحقيقه اذا كان نظر
الدكتور ايضا الى هؤلاء الشعراء واعطانا
ايضا بعض اخبارهم وهناك ايضا شعراء كثيرين
جدا غير هؤلاء لكن بالمقابل اذا كانت هذه
الفئه من الشعراء لفتوا هذا الانتباه عفوا
فان هناك ايضا فئه اخرى الذين هم العلماء
وطلاب العلم لفت ايضا الى هذا الامر ولهذا
نجد ايضا العلماء منذ ايام العالم الكبير
المشهور احمد بن عطوه الذي توفي سنه 1948
من علماء العارض وايضا استقروا في الدرعيه
في فتره من الفترات وايضا كان له يعني
احكام وايضا احكام شرعيه هناك انتقل الى
الشام فكان يذكر لي ايضا علماء الشام في
تلك الفتره واقع الحاله الامنيه في هذه
المنطقه وما هي الاحكام التي ستطبق وكذلك
ايضا لدينا فتوى مشهوره يعني اذا كان
نظرنا في هذا الجانب الامني هناك فتوى
مشهوره لعالم الرياض الشيخ عبد الله بن
محمد بن هلال كانت الشيخ عبد الله بن محمد
بن دلال توفي تقريبا في عام
1999 في ذي الحجه قبل الدوله وايضا قبل
قيام الدوله وايضا لكن كان تاثيره هو
المجدد ايضا الثاني او الثالث العلماء
الحنابله في هذه المنطقه فكان تعرض عليه
القضايا ايضا الامنيه يعني اذا كان تعرض
عليه القضايا الامنيه في كتاب مشهور اسمه
الفواكه العديده في المسائل المفيده للشيخ
احمد بن محمد بن منقور الذي توفي في سنه
112 في حمل هذا الكتاب اسئله وعجائب
وغرائب وفرائض ايضا للحاله الواقعه في هذه
المنطقه مثلا يشير ايضا هذا العالم
يسالونه الناس يقولون ما رايك يا شيخ كيف
يستطيع الناس الحج ونحن لا نستطيع الامن
فهل يجوز ايضا ان نستاجر اناس يحمون ايضا
مسيرتنا لهذا الاتجاه فقال الشيخ نعم
يجوز لكم ذلك وهؤلاء يسمون الرفق الرفق
يعني يرافقه في الطريق فيدفع عليه مبلغ
الحمايه هؤلاء يدفع عليهم مبلغ الحمايه
ليتاجون المقدسه هناك ايضا الشيخ عبد الله
بن محمد بن دلال له فتوى ايضا كان ابن
غشام شاعر مشهور توفي تقريبا قتل سنه 1970
فكان الشيخ ايضا
نعم فكان ايضا هناك اشكالات فكانوا يسالون
الشيخ يقول من ينفذ هذه الاحكام وينشر
العدل فيقول الشيخ انا افديكم بجواز قتله
لان لا احد الحقيقه يستطيع تنفيذ مثل هذه
الاحكام فالناحيه الامنيه كانت الحقيقه
يعني هو بوصفه عالم او رجل دين يعتقد ان
هذا الرجل او الامير في هذه القريه انه
ظالم ويظلم الناس ويقول لك لا يوجد سلطه
مركزيه تنفذ هذا الامر لا اشك في قتله
رميزان يعني لا
اشكاليه اللي كان ما كان هناك قوه وسلطه
سياسيه تجبرها هؤلاء على ايضا الامن
والامان الذين يعني الذي يتطلبوا هذا
المجتمع ولهذا لدينا القاعده الاساسيه في
قيام الدوله والعنصر الكبير انه الجانب
الامني هو اعظم عامل لقيام الدوله لانه
الناس اذكر لبعض الاخوه يقولون ربما
تجاوزت الجانب الديني او الجانب ايضا
الدعوي نقول لهم نحن نفقد الجانب الامني
ولم نفقد الدين الدين منذ وصول هذه
الرساله المحمديه صلى الله عليه وسلم ايضا
الى هذه المنطقه انتشرت واصبح الناس ايضا
في الاسلام ومطبقين للتعاليم والاركان
فكيف تقول لي انه جدد الدين انا اقول
الدين موجود ثابت وابائنا واجدادنا اذا
اخذنا
القانوني اللي هو الفقه والقضاء هو هذا
اللي فيه اتصال مباشر بحياه النسخ غير
الاحكام الشخصيه
الوضوء والصلاه هذا الجانب يعني مثلا
النزاعات التجاريه اللي هو الجانب
التشريعي والقانوني لا بد له من سلطه صحيح
وهذا الجانب الذي كان يفقده في يفقد في
هذه المنطقه لان الامراء في هذه المنطقه
عندما بدا ايضا محمد بن سعود بفكره
التنفيذ وايضا تطلع للسلطه وايضا بث القوه
وايضا النفوذ للبلدان المجاوره الرياض
سرمدا الخرج شعروا هؤلاء بان هذا النفوذ
سيؤثر عليهم ولذلك واجهوه بالقوه ولهذا
نجد في الكتابات الحميدان الشويعر تحدث عن
فساد بعض القضاه اي نعم قضاه ياخذون
الرشاوه ماذا يحظر وجزء منهم ايضا لكن
كانوا يعني وشيوخ يعني ايضا بقصائد رميزان
ايضا يشير الى الحاله الامنين التي كانت
سائده في هذه المنطقه وايضا معاناه الناس
في هذه الحاله ويقول ان المجتمع حتى في
قيام انطلاقه الدوله السعوديه ومشروعها
التوحيدي وايضا نشر الامن لا يمكن ان نكون
رغم النصوص الموجوده الان لا يمكن ان نقول
والله محمد بن سعود انتقل الى هذا البلد
لكي يفعل مثلا يزيل القبر الفلاني او كذا
الفلاني كانت الانتقال محاوله لملمه هذه
الاطراف وايضا ادخالها بالقوه تحت نفوذه
واحد ولهذا شعر ايضا هؤلاء الامراء بهذا
الشعور انه سيفقد ايضا نصيبه من الحكم لكن
محمد بن سعود عنده لديه تطلع كبير للسيطره
على هذه
اعتقد حتى لا يعتقد الناس اننا نرمي
الكلام جزافا يعني قبل لقائه بالشيخ محمد
الدرعيه قاومه النفوذ حكم الاحسن وهي
الاماره الاحساء الاماره الخالديه اماره
الاحساء كانت اقوى اماره في وسط وشرق
الجزيره العربيه ومع ذلك استطاعت الدرعيه
ان يعني تتمتع بنوع من الحكم الذاتي وان
تخرج عكس بقيه البلدات وايضا نجد لها
صراعات ايضا في هذه المنطقه في القوه
المحليه ايضا بقياده ايضا محمد بن سعود
وايضا يعني الدرعيه كانت فتره من الفترات
ايضا هناك عدد الحقيقه من العلماء وايضا
هناك من الدعاء موجودين في الدرعيه يعني
اذا بدانا من مثلا من الشيخ احمد بن عطوه
الى ان نصل الى علماء اسره الباهلي علماء
اسره الباهلي سليمان الباهلي وكانوا ايضا
بارزين ايضا في هذه المنطقه في ايام
الامام محمد مسعود وقبل كلهم حنابله نعم
نعم طيب على كل حال انا اعتقد انه ما زال
في اللعبه الاتفاقيه ولذلك استاذنك دكتور
راشد ان نكمل الحديث في حلقه ثانيه لان ما
احس انه الامر لم نشبعه حق حقه
المستحق يعني
بالبقاء معنا للحلقه اخرى ان شاء الله
الاسبوع المقبل كما
نستميحكم ايضا عذرا في هذا القطع المؤقت
على ان نستكمل الحديث في حلقه مقبله فلا
تذهب عنها بعيدا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]